convertir un vélo et bien je change le
moteur un capteur de pédalier on intègre
des capteurs au niveau du frein un
afficheur avec l'oni ou l'assistance et
divers informations et une ampoule 36
volts de convertir votre vélo classique
en lui ajoutant une assistance
électrique c'est le pari de cette
ancienne employée du secteur
aéronautique qui vient tout juste
d'installer son atelier dans une petite
commune de l'est tourangeau
coût de l'opération environ 750 euros
moins cher qu'un vélo électrique neuf de
milieu de gamme
le petit plus apporté ici c'est la
batterie qu'il prépare avec un soin
particulier
l'avantagé que les batteries c'est moi
qui les a semble donc je les achète pas
dans le commerce
et donc c'est moi qui choisis les
cellules qui sont installés et tout le
tout l'électronique qui garantit une
batterie de bonne qualité on ne peut
pourtant pas dire que christophe barraud
était du genre passionné par la petite
reine
le vélo je je n'aime pas ça à la base
c'est pas très confortable et puis
toujours cette crainte d'avoir les les
cuisses en feu mais avant de se
convertir lui aussi aux bienfaits du
vélo électrique c'est l'impérieuse
nécessité de changer de métier qui l'a
conduit à cette nouvelle activité
j'étais à la limite du burn out et
j'avais vraiment besoin de retrouver du
sens donc donc aujourd'hui
je démarre ma propre activité c'est un
risque que l'on prend ce risque est pris
en famille
mais par contre c'est une joie que je
retrouve tous les matins d'aller d'aller
au travail depuis une semaine
ça n'arrête pas j'ai pas mal de verrous
genre dont il y en a une bonne partie à
l'atelier j'en ai encore d'autres
derrière et la semaine prochaine j'ai
encore des clients qui attendent de
savoir s'ils peuvent déposer de dorval
ou pas un démarrage sur les chapeaux de
roue donc et un carnet de commandes qui
se remplit à vue d'oeil
de quoi rassurer le jeune chef
d'entreprise sur le bien fondé de son
activité